[Applause]
great to be back with you here on
tuesday night the nba on tnt
101.85 pelicans oh my goodness deep one
take me and lillard unlimited range
oh just look how deep this is i mean
there's really
seventh ranked scoring defense in the
league giving up
115.5 points per game lillard attacking
hayes
he's now got 35. it looked like it was a
travel did he shift his pivot
foot i mean it looks so smooth
lillard a three
ingram knock away and an opportunity
here for portland lillard
the drive the bucket gets it back with
13 to shoot
tight defense there from bledsoe fake
against the grain
bullseye a three for damien lillard
is ahead for good oh look at that fake
off done
lillard hesitation and one
for damian lillard chants at a
three-point play
worried about the three-point shooting
of lillard
he understands when the switch happens
whipley
try to miss the second to try to get an
offensive rebound or since you do have
that one timeout remaining
five point two left portland down by two
second attempt it's good it's part of
the ball but
it affects the shooter
124 124
portland takes the lead toss it up the
floor zion at the horn
bank shot doesn't go the blazers
rally for an unlikely win down the
stretch